[Musique]
nous sommes au premier étage de la tour
beauvoir en compagnie du dessinateur
chaval ses planches ont été réalisées au
siècle dernier
elle raconte le quotidien notre
quotidien observer avec humour que nous
apprécier mois savall le côté absurde
le cet humour de l'absurde par exemple
ce monsieur qui va écraser une mouche
avec un marteau mais sur sa fenêtre
certains dessins sont partis sont assez
noir chez chaval c'est pas le côté que
je préfère mais par contre le
le musicien qui fait sortir des bulles
de savon et sa trompette
voilà ce cet humour de l'absurde moi me
plaît bien
shaval de son vrai nom yves ans francis
le louarn est né à bordeaux en 1915
aujourd'hui ces dessins sont toujours
d'actualité comme cette série sur la
corrida
quand il tourne en dérision la corrida
dans ses dessins c'est c'est vraiment
une prise de position que l'on a
maintenant 2
de se moquer de la corrida pour la
combattre c'est une prise de position
encore plus courageuse à l'époque que
maintenant c'est vrai que le dessin
d'humour peut aussi être sa une
faire passer des idées plus forte gelée
était intéressant de mettre en avant
justement parce qu'il est très peu connu
il a pourtant été assez assez prolifique
travailler avec des journaux comme
france soir mais
le grand public le connaît peu donc
c'était une façon de lui rendre hommage
et le faire ta m shaval a également
beaucoup joué avec la mort la tournant
souvent en dérision
en 1968 il va même jusqu'à la provoquer
pour de vrai et disparaître depuis
chaval est au ciel et nous amuse encore